corporate showdowns box office
catastrophes and a future that's
uncertain to say the least this is the
rise and fall of Henry cavill's Superman
on the heels of the 2008 box office
sensation Iron Man Warner Brothers NDC
were forced to play catch-up hoping to
make a splash in pop culture history DC
leaned on Superman to pave the way for
its own movie crossover franchise more
pressingly a Court ruling in favor of
soup's original creators stated that the
family of Jerry Siegel would be able to
sue the studio for damages and reclaim
the rights to the character if a new
Superman movie did not go into
production by 2011. meanwhile actor
Henry Cavill had been waiting for his
chance to star in a top grossing
Hollywood feature Cavill had been
reportedly passed up for major roles in
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
Twilight and the James Bond reboot
Casino Royale caval's coveted bone
structure and buff physique had seen him
rumored as superhero for many years and
he was even one of the first choices for
the 2006 movie Superman Returns finally
after many near-misses Cavill was
announced for the leading role of Clark
Kent and Zack Snyder's Man of Steel with
the director boasting that he was the
perfect choice for the part
at nearly 10 years old the DC extended
Universe has been something of a messy
adventure with the final few films of
the Cinematic franchise set to trickle
out in 2023 DC's rivalry with the MCU
could be called one of the most
expensive failed movie experiments of
all time with a mishmash of reboots
unclear timelines and far too many Loose
Ends the dceu will conclude with more
canceled projects than completed films
at the center of it all was a Justice
League film that became so convoluted
that it had two separate releases each
completed by two different directors
booyah
the box office disaster that was Justice
League is a well-documented Hollywood
hiccup one that sought director Zack
Snyder leaving the movie mid project for
personal reasons only to find his vision
of the dceu left in shambles upon his
return a late attempt at patchworking
his franchise centerpiece into existence
in 2021 proved to be too little too late
as Warner Brothers searched for new
directions in James Gunn's The Suicide
Squad reboot and a rock-led Black Adam
film notably two of the movies that
Henry Cavill was most heavily featured
in Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
and Justice League were arguably the
most critically penned
the aftermath of Justice League led to a
retooling of the entire DC EU a film
intended to spin off into at least six
movies and have a minimum of two sequels
ended with just two follow-ups Aquaman
and Wonder Woman 1984 with multiple
projects from the headlining performers
of the dceu canceled Henry cavill's
future with Warner Brothers has been
uncertain since his last starring role
in 2017. conversely Cavill has struggled
to break through as a superstar in other
Hollywood projects one of the actor's
most significant roles outside of the
dceu as Napoleon Solo in The Man from
Uncle led to one of the biggest box
office flops of 2015 making matters
worse Cavill became the target of
Internet ridicule for his inconsistent
upper lip between Mission Impossible
Fallout and Justice League although the
runaway's success Fallout at least made
up for all that still aside from a
moderately successful appearance at
Sherlock Holmes in Enola homes Cavill
has remained outside the bubble of
A-list movie stars in his adventures
beyond the world of DC
everybody could smell what The Rock was
cooking when he brought Henry Cavill
back for a surprise cameo in the
mid-credits scene of 2022's Black Adam
Black Adam
we should talk
Dwayne Johnson was ready to forge ahead
with his vision for the dceu as he
championed the introduction of the
entire Justice Society along with the
return of Clark Kent himself a
significant part of the marketing for
Black Adam involved the former WWE
wrestler touting his own Rebrand for the
Cinematic franchise as the movie reached
moderate critical Acclaim Rock boastly
tweeted Black Adam will serve as our
phase one of Storytelling in our DC
Universe exciting times for the brand to
build up and build Out The Rock's idea
for the revamped DCU involved one vital
character of course Superman if nothing
else Johnson wanted his new anti-hero on
screen with the last son of Krypton in
another post he wrote we fought for
years to bring you back they always said
no no was never an option we can't build
out our dceu without the world's
greatest superhero
following the release of Black Adam the
news spread quickly that Henry Cavill
was about to step back into the blue and
red suit then at last Henry Cavill made
the announcement that Kal-El would be
back on Instagram he said I wanted to
make it official that I am back as
Superman unbeknownst to caval at the
time the dceu was about to undergo its
greatest change yet it came to light
almost simultaneously with cavil's
announcement that James Gunn and Peter
saffron were being handed the keys to
the DC cinematic Kingdom with the
character's future in their hands Cavill
may have been preemptive when saying he
was enormously joyful about his comeback
just days earlier understanding what has
come to light since regarding cavill's
dismissal it's unclear how the Cameo and
supposed dceu return were presented to
the actor the fans were also left
without a clear explanation as to what
the studio heads at the time intended
for Superman's next flight
like two alternate timelines two
parallel DC movie franchises were being
built in different directions during
that fateful week in late October one
was being brainstormed by James Gunn and
Peter saffron as they prepared for their
first days on the job the other was the
dceu as constructed by Dwayne Johnson
and his team with Black Adam proving to
be a last-ditch effort for Warner
Brothers before going in a completely
new Direction much of the truth about
that week has yet to be revealed
whatever really happened there were for
a time high expectations for a sequel to
caval's only solo Superman feature Man
of Steel although it was never announced
fans were led to believe that a new
movie starring Cavill as the DC
headliner was in development even as it
was reported that the former head of the
dceu Walter Hamada was on his way out
The Hollywood Reporter stated that the
Studio's eyes are very much on Superman
but Cavill once again missed the mark in
October 2022 when he stepped away from
his leading role in Netflix's The
Witcher presumably under the impression
he he would soon be filming a big budget
DC picture
adding to the confusion regarding the
definitive direction of the dceu there
were and are multiple other projects in
various stages of development as it
stands titles like Shazam 2 Fury of the
Gods and Blue Beetle are still set for
release on their respective Premiere
dates in March and August 2023. Aquaman
and the lost kingdom is equally likely
to maintain its Christmas 2023 Premiere
conversely a slew of other potential
projects have more or less hit the waste
basket including Black Canary and Wonder
Woman 3. Patty Jenkins had been working
under the perception that she would be
able to include her Wonder Woman trilogy
but recently revealed that her and gal
gadot's future in the dceu is anything
but assured that leaves just one movie
oh wow they just they really just vanish
huh oh
that's rude somehow the flesh is still
on deck at DC and for a while it was
supposed to feature cameos from nearly
every original member of the Cinematic
Justice League although Ben Affleck is
still reportedly in the film as Batman
the Multiverse jumping movie has now
lost story Fisher as cyborg gal gadot's
Wonder Woman and Henry cavill's Superman
although the scenes previously filmed by
cavil were reportedly still attached to
the film as of early December 2022 The
Cameo was reported to have been cut just
a few weeks later
regardless of anyone else's plans for
the DC Cinematic Universe James Gunn and
Peter Safran are now indisputably in
charge of the franchise going forward
despite officially taking over on
November 1st 2022 Gunn has been
preoccupied with wrapping up production
on Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 for
Marvel gun even managed to release the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
amidst the chaos of the last couple
months so it's understandable that gun
and saffron haven't been able to
solidify a plan for their newly
configured DCU until recently taking on
a position of such influence requires a
little adjustment but as saffron and
Gunn toiled away at a new outline for
the DCU the director was not shy about
teasing the future clearly avoiding the
layers of secrecy for which Marvel is so
notorious gun has posted images on
social media of certain characters that
were presumably under consideration for
big screen adaptations including Lobo Mr
terrific and the Aged Heroes of the
Kingdom Come story arc finally on
December 14th gun updated fans on the
status of the franchise tweeting Peter
Safran and I have a DC slate ready to go
we'll be able to share some exciting
information about our first projects at
the beginning of the new year
in the same thread James Gunn Dropped a
Bomb on one particular corner of his new
DCU gun revealed among those on the
Slate is Superman in the initial stages
our story will be focusing on an earlier
part of Superman's life so the character
will not be played by Henry Cavill the
news was a shock considering the hype
around Man of Steel 2 had been
progressively building to that moment
Gunn continued but we just had a great
meeting with Henry and we talked about a
number of exciting possibilities to work
together in the future Cavill took to
Instagram to confirm the same news in
his post he sent one final message of
Hope from the actor who was the man of
steel for nearly a decade Superman is
still around everything he stands for
exists and the examples he sets for us
are still there my turn to where the
cape has passed but what Superman stands
for never will
if nothing else fans who have advocated
for Zack Snyder's original concept of
the DC EU have been outspoken and
passionate even as Peter Safran and
James Gunn solidify their new outline
for the comic book franchise many of
those fans have been as loud as ever
while not every fanatic has been
completely opposed to the redirection
there has been a flurry of social media
campaigns asking to bring back Zack
Snyder and restore the Snyder verse
meanwhile Dwayne Johnson who advocated
for Henry Cavill to be reinstated as
Superman in the first place has been
eerily quiet about the dismissal as he
awaits his own news about the future of
Black Adam
there's no one on this planet that can
stop me some have been quick to blame
the former wrestler for exploiting the
return of Cavill in his attempt to take
control of the dceu subsequently many of
kavel's dceu peers including Jason Momoa
and Zachary Levi have reached out with
their own messages in the comments of
the former man of Steel's Instagram
announcement meanwhile Black Adam
producer Danny Garcia wrote you are and
will always be our Superman
many DC fans are now looking forward to
the future of the last son of Krypton
the film that gun has been scripting
will not retell kalel's origin story
again but will focus instead on his
earlier days as a hero yet despite
Warner Brothers Discovery CEO David
saslof's mandate to cut back on multiple
versions of DC Superheroes existing at
the same time there is one more Superman
movie in the works tanahasi coats has
been scripting his own version of the
Man of Steel stories since February 2021
which would introduce a black Superman
to the world of DC Cinema the new film
which is not attached to the DC EU has
been produced by JJ Abrams and his Bad
Robot company while many DC projects
have hit the chopping block in recent
days no cancellation for this project
has been announced yet
[Music]
foreign
[Music]